بعد ان بقيت عالقه هنا في معبر التائهه
لمده اسبوع كامل ها هي هذه الشاحنات المئه
المحمله بالوقود والمخصصه للمنكوبين في
مناطق حلب بالتحرك نحو مناطق النظام وبعد
ذلك بعد الوصول الى توافق بين الاداره
الذاتيه ونظام السوري تم بموجبه السماح
لهذه الشاحنات بالتحرك والدخول الى
المناطق الخاضعه للسيطره النظام وفق
المعلومات المتوفره لدينا فان نظام سيقوم
بتوزيع 60 شاحنه منها على المتضررين في
مناطق مختلفه من حلب بينما ستتولى الاداره
الذاتيه بتوزيع اربعين شاحنه 30 شاحنه في
مخيم الشهباء الذي يضمه عشرات الالاف من
نازحين مدينه عفرين وعشر شاحنات اخرى في
حي الشيخ مقصود وبالتالي تكون الاداره
الذاتيه
النظام قد تواصلا الى تفاهم مبدئي يتيح
بحركه عبور المساعدات من معبر التائهه
الذي يفصل بين مناطق سيطره الطرفين في
مدينه منبج السوريه وينهي فصلا من فصول
اغلاق المعابر الداخليه بين الاطراف
المتصارعه على المشهد السوري من معبر
التائهه في مدينه منبج ومعكاش لقناتي
العربيه والحدث